wenn der geräuschemacher zur arbeit geht
wirkt lediglich das gemüse als
pausensnack etwas bizarr doch von den
lebensmitteln ist nur die cola für ihn
bestimmt im sound design studio in bern
vertont olaf simon einen tierfilm denn
manchmal konnte oder wollte das
kamerateam mit dem mikrofon einfach
nicht mehr heran ans geschehen und so
werden seine löwen vom sound her zu
vegetariern das geräusch dichter zur
spitze unterstützen also es färbt das
bild noch mal gibt dem so einen
emotionalen charakter
ob der jetzt brutal zu beißt oder ob er
jetzt ganz sanft zubeißt das lässt sich
alles viel besser über die ohren
erzählen als über das bild manche sind
schon so alt wie der tonfilm selbst
nutze benutze ich weil sie einfach schon
seit fast 100 jahren im film existieren
und die würde ich einfach total echt an
also der zuschauer hat die kokosnüsse
schon so in seinem ohr etabliert dass
sie echte klingen als die originale
hinzu kommt der geräuschemacher ist
präzise und schneller als jedes digitale
geräusch archiv in alltagsszenen sind
viele geräusche gleichzeitig zu hören
in dem film der große sommer der letzte
mit mathias gnädinger sind es allein für
diese drei minuten szene 18 verschiedene
geräusche die olaf simon einspielt von
drei verschiedenen schritten und dem
chip an der schüssel bis zum brechen der
stäbchen bei dreharbeiten wird nur ein
gesamten aufgenommen
ein brei aus allen geräuschen erst durch
getrennte töne kann der regisseur die
aufmerksamkeit der zuschauer lenken
entweder auf die menschen durch ihre
schritte oder auf das essen durch das
geschirr klappern wenn der große
sommeranfang 2016 in die kinos kommt
wird keiner mehr sehen wieviel arbeit
von olaf simon darin steckt
noch tiefer verborgen zwei stockwerke
unter der erde
das hörspiel studio von sf 2 kultur hier
kommt man ganz ohne bilder aus extremer
noch der regisseur wolfram hall will
dass seine zuhörer eine welt imaginären
die es in der realität gar nicht gibt
deswegen geht er nicht zu irgendeinem
realen gletscher sondern kreiert seinen
eigenen sound des eises die schweizer
himalaya expeditionen in den 50er jahren
sind der reale hintergrund der
geschichte erfunden ist die figur eines
jungen kartografen der den gletscher
quartieren soll das tolle am hörspiel
ist ja unter anderem auch man kann den
kletter behaupten wir können jetzt
wirklich sagen wir sind im klatsche wir
sind auf dem mount everest aber eben in
einem so realen klettern
man merkt vielleicht sogar noch der
diese geräusche die werden aus papier
gemacht und es aber ihm trotzdem ein
gletscher die hauptfigur des stücks ist
ein kleiner junger mann ein buch
schreiben muss und er habe eigentlich
keine ahnung von dem von dem echten
gletscher für mechtenberg und in dieser
szene wird quasi von von dem gletscher
forscher einen professor in seinem
zimmer gerufen und von da geht
eigentlich eine direkte tür in den
gletscher
welches gletscher tun das tor dort unten
am ende dieses wohnraumes hier kollege
wir sind mittendrin
wir sind in grenzen später wenn das
hörspiel fertig ist und die zuhörer dem
radio lauschen dann hören zwar alle
dasselbe
doch jeder sieht etwas anderes im
kinofilm musste das geräusch den bildern
folgen
das hörspiel schafft seine eigene welt
aus klang